[Music]
Dave it's so weird because what we're
seeing right now is everybody running
from Dei even Democratic candidates are
running from it and yet this is still up
on the Navy website does this scare you
Greg I will talk about that but can we
talk about your glasses first because
you you look like a middle-aged lesbian
poet
which which actually might be Dei for
Fox that's Dave Rubin killing it on
Gutfeld exclamation point on Friday Fox
news program Gutfeld with Greg Gutfeld
it's January 17th 2024 I'm Dave rman
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals share subscribe tap that
notification Bell and if I'm not
mistaken there is an issue with locals
right now we're having a little locals
issue if you normally watch on locals uh
you're probably watching on Rumble right
now so take an extra moment and tap that
subscribe button would you do that for
me uh okay guys obviously there is
something major to talk about then we'll
dive into a normal show and everything
else but Ronda santis uh has dropped out
of the presidential race this thing is
Trump's lose at this point Nikki's
hanging around there's the gov who is
now back in Tallahassee and we will
continue to strengthen the free state of
Florida I just want to say first uh now
it's not that this was such a surprise
over the weekend right like he was the
Trump was basically the presumptive
nominee last week the entire DeSantis
strategy really was go hard 99 counties
in Iowa see if you can win there or at
least get a close second so you shift
The Narrative a little bit from Trump
being Unstoppable he ends up getting
about 20% doesn't work work out despite
the fact that the the amount of people
who showed up at the Iowa caucuses was
extremely depressed about 100,000 people
voted so everything is sort of being
painted within the parameters of a
100,000 people voting 50,000 voting for
Trump that gets V to drop out now Des
santis drops out Nikki's really the last
one obviously Christy and a couple
others had dropped out even before that
um I just want to say first off that it
is always this is Rel relative to Ronda
santis and everything El and and
everything else in life I would say it
is always worth fighting the good fight
you will not always win Donald Trump
does not always win he lost the last
presidential election um when I was in
California I fought very hard for the
recall of Gavin Newsome that did not
work right I I campaigned with lar Elder
it was worth doing I think fighting for
good people and fighting for the right
ideas are always worth doing and and
it's not just about if you get the
political win or not uh I will also say
something that I I repeated on the show
I think several times over the last year
or so even before Dan santis had
officially announced that he was running
that as a Floridian uh one of my
concerns was oh we're going to send our
best guy who's basically done everything
right in this state this state that that
is a sanctuary for Freedom lovers in
America we're going to send our best guy
out into into the chaos of the crazy
machine that destroys everybody whether
we're talking about the swamp or whether
we're talking about going against Donald
Trump and would he come back irreparably
wounded if if he doesn't win now I don't
think so I think he's going to be just
fine and and the continued wins of
Florida will just will just go like
dominoes so in a in a weird way when he
announced this over the weekend I was
kind of relieved I was like all right it
didn't look like it was going to happen
so it was but we were still sort of
neither here nor there last week after
the Iowa LW and before he had announced
anything and I'm like oh well we got our
best guy back right now so as a Floridan
I want to say that but but my buddy Dave
R boy who's been on the show uh many
times he's an author National Security
expert uh he had a really nice tweet
about this Dave's been living in in
Florida for I think about 15 years or so
uh he wrote this he wrote of course I'm
disappointed but at the end of the day I
live in the greatest State barnun Ronda
santis is Florida and there's no close
second Florida was never my idea of a
paradise or a refuge while it was
governed by middle-of the road Chamber
of Commerce Republicans like Jeb Bush D
and Broward County and pal Beach had the
politics of a tropical Jersey in 2018
there was absolutely no reason for
Florida to become the Vanguard of
right-wing governance but it was Ronda
Santos who won that election and he
changed everything so much of my life
here from Freedom during covid the
amazing energy dynamism and optimism
across the whole state to my wonderful
friends who've moved here is owed in
large part to the best most based
elected official of the last 50 years
cataloging everything he accomplished in
only six years reads like a dream for
the American right the santis made his
mark on every issue we said we cared
about we were amazed at how he never
folded against the left and turned
around and kept scoring based victories
he left the Democrat Party of Florida
like roadkill on the turnpike he has
been a leader far better than we deserve
it seems because he took he took
seriously the things the right always
claim that it wanted for that he will
always have my support in any capacity
thank you governor
I'd like to say thank you Dave R boy
because you just made my job very easy
because you summed up all my feelings
and I just had to read a tweet by you so
yes Florida will remain strong we will
see what Ronda sanz's future is beyond
Florida potentially if he ever wanted to
run again or be involved in the
administration or anything else but look
you you you can either bend the world to
your will or you can see the world as it
is I voted for Trump last time uh I was
out there heavily supporting the guy
then I I thought that there was a better
choice I thought there was a younger
version of him with all of the good
stuff and none of the baggage then all
these court cases came and all the rest
of it and clearly at least the people of
Iowa and the way our political system
works uh it's not heading in the
direction that I thought it was and and
that's actually just fine so as I said
all along if Trump is the nominee I'm
going to vote for him and uh and here we
are so it's all good but now let me
connect that to what I want do with the
show today because one of the things
that I think I'll probably struggle with
a little bit over the next year or so or
at least for the 10 months of this
campaign is that you know how often I
talk about truth on this show how often
I show uh clips of Jordan Peterson
talking about truth and how often I've
said that you know the easy thing about
supporting the santis was it's like it's
so rare that there's a politician that
tells truth so you don't have to contort
yourself to constantly just agree with
or back or promote everything he says
because you're like oh it's true it's
simple it's good that's it and by the
way I think that's one of the things
that he suffered from as a candidate
just kind of being good right I called
it the Tim Duncan syndrome or it's the
Tony Gwyn syndrome I think that's what
Steve Dace called it if you're
consistently batting 350 people aren't
excited when you get another base hit
Tim Duncan you win another uh another
MVP another Finals MVP five time champ
nobody cares anymore right and I think
the Santa suffered from a bit of that
but I think one of the things that's
going to be a through line on this show
for the next year is that I don't want
to go into this just worshiping and
ignoring the lies and everything else
but clearly Trump is a zillion times
better than anything that the Democrats
are putting out there and the fact that
Joe Biden has dementia and they've
ushered in all of the wokeism and we
have no border and anything else so I am
going to constantly constantly be
pushing and promoting the people that
are telling the truth that are fighting
the narratives and everything
else and occasionally that's going to
come with having to uh you know shed a
little light on some of Trump's nonsense
too and that gets me to where I want to
start culturally for today that was a
long ass intro but I think you will see
it will be worthwhile uh you know one of
the big cultural uh touchstones that we
have in this country right now is the
UFC uh I am not a huge UFC fighting guy
uh and some of you are not either but I
do show these clips because millions of
millions of people in this country are
paying attention to what is happening in
the UFC and how it's become sort of
politicized and associated with Trump so
when you're surprised or if you were
surprised that Trump is now the
presumptive nominee basically unless
Nikki pulls off like the Hail Mary of
all time uh it's partly because of what
is happening culturally that's why I'm
always more interested in talking about
culture which is Downstream politics is
Downstream from culture as Andrew
Breitbart said I'm always more
interested in that than just like oh
what happened politically today and
let's fight about all that anyway the
UFC had a huge fight this weekend it was
the middleweight championship and it was
up in Canada and Joe Rogan was doing a
live stream of this thing so it was a
simal cast where they're watching the
fight and you're watching Joe with a
couple of his guests and there was a
massive chance in the audience in Canada
F Trudeau and I think this is indicative
of largely what is happening right now
and what is driving the movement behind
Trump let's take a
look TR the yell true love
it love it
yeah get your together come back come
back to what you used to be that Pierre
po guy however you say his name that guy
makes sense he's also Fidel Castro's kid
we know I'm I'm not a big conspiracy Guy
come on come on Eddie back me up on this
educate them it's not that crazy it's
not that crazy all right again you may
not care that much about UFC again I say
it's not really my thing but I'm trying
to show you when when you watch
newscasts and they miss all of the
culture stuff and then you wonder how
did Trump returned it's because of
things like this it's interesting by the
way Joe Rogan who again I don't even
think voted in the last election and by
no means is a classic conservative he
says I like Pierre PO he he is the
conservative party leader in Canada
right now but the fact that thousands of
people are showing up to a UFC fight to
say F the prime minister of Canada the
guy who shut down the truckers and the
bank accounts and all of that and was
was one of the worst sort of covid
authoritarians in the entire world it
shows you that the people have just sort
of had it with the elitists and the
globalists and and the Machine here's a
bit more of the crowd chanting F
Trudeau now I want to connect this to
something that I think is more largely
happening in the country like why is it
happening why are these people showing
up to a fight to scream F the Prime
Minister well there was a specific
reason for it in this case uh over the
weekend there was a press conference for
this fight and UFC middleweight champ
his name is Shan Strickland uh he got
into it with a reporter a woke reporter
of course uh trying to get him on some
past comments and I want you to watch
how it doesn't even matter if you
completely agree with him or not or
agree with the reporter or not I want
you to watch how he fights back on the
woke reporter and then think does that
remind you of a certain orange man who's
suddenly
surging uh we've got a pretty Sur of gay
and lesbian community in this city I did
want to ask you about something you
wrote A couple of years ago you said if
I had a gay son I would think i' oh look
another another I'm saying the swamp you
guys the swamp you've become a champion
you become a star and and someone let me
ask you something are you are you are
you gay the chance back with more divers
are you let me know are you gay can I
can I get answer question well I'm
asking this is a part of are you are you
a gay man I'm an ally of the community
okay if you had a son and he was like
you know he had a son he was gay you'd
be like oh man you don't you don't want
a grandkid no problem with it oh man
well dude you're a weak man dude you're
like you're part of the problem you
elected Justin Trudeau like with you
when he sees the bank accounts like
you're just pathetic and and the fact
that the fact that you have no backbone
and and has he shut down your country
and sees bank accounts you ask me some
stupid like that go yourself move the on
man question he's well spoken I'll give
him that much um okay it doesn't even
matter if you agree with all of the
specifics and I could get into some of
the Nuance there um it that's not really
the point the broader point is that this
guy uh is going after the media in a
very trumpy and way and that led to when
he's talking about what Trudeau did with
the truckers and everything else you
were he's basically saying it's people
like you that led to this effed up
situation in this country and then
thousands of people start chanting F
Trudeau it's like there's a connection
there there's a connection between how
those things are happening and there's
also a connection that finally a whole
bunch of us and it doesn't mean that I
agree with everything that this
Strickland guy says or I agree with
everything that Trump says but enough of
us are just like enough F you people not
just F Trudeau F all of you people who
have guilted us and gone after us and
tried to shut down our bank accounts and
everything else so the problem of course
with the woke is that they are so
fixated on these faux social issues uh
that they actually ignore real T tyranny
when it comes from the real tyrants but
I want to show we we'll get into that in
just a sec I want to show you a bit more
from that press conference with
Strickland because he's also not having
it uh with Bud Light and uh and the
trans thing but I did want to ask also
things you said about the trans
Community you said uh this past October
when they announced the Bud Light
sponsorship that you'd go so hard on Bud
Light in your next fight they'll have to
accept me or denounce me when uh when
they know what and will know what they
stand for are you this guy's like d this
Canadian is not that Canadian are you
still going to use your fight time to
kind of speak on that here's the thing
about Bud
Light
here's the thing about Bud
Light 10 years ago to be trans was a
what a mental illness and now all of a
sudden people like you have weasel your
way in the
world you are you are an
infection you are the definition of
weakness everything that is wrong with
the world is because of you and the best
thing is is the world's not buying it
the world's not buying your bull you're
pedling the world is not saying you know
what you're right chicks have dicks the
world's not saying that world saying no
there are two genders I don't want my
kids being taught about you know who
they could in school I don't want my
kids being taught about you know their
sexual preference like do this guy is
the enemy you want to look at the enemy
to our world it's that mother right
there asking these stupid
questions okay again you don't have to
agree with exactly how he's saying it or
anything else um but he he is like
directionally right and also again it
illustrates the broader point of enough
people have had enough of this and you
know when I talk about how I don't watch
the NBA anymore because everything's
been so politicized it's like do you
think that that this guy when he was
training to be a great Fighter for years
and years and years thought that oh
mostly when he would be giving press
conferences before the biggest fight of
his life he'd be talking about whether
girls or boys and boys are girls and
everything else so it has woke is M has
infected literally everything in society
from the military down to the UFC and
everything in between and now people
have had enough and again I would
connect that exactly to the to the
rocket fuel that is behind Trump right
now right that is the rocket fuel that
made a lot of people say okay because
nobody hated the STIs but people are
like all right to say this he's good
he's fine he's fighting the right fights
but Trump is the guy that they associate
with this thing I want to show you one
more from Strickland cuz he doesn't hate
the gays the language is a little
whatever but he doesn't really hate the
gays he just doesn't want this crap
taught in schools which 10 years ago
would have been the position of every
sane human being on this great Planet
I'm trying to be good man I'm trying to
be good I do I like the gays here's
thing I've never you you guys think I've
ever on a gay man or on a gay one I
don't I like the gays it's it's a it's
it's Freedom we still have it in America
we'll teach you about it you guys don't
have freedom of speech I'm surprised
what I'm saying it's probably gonna get
I'm probably gonna get the Canadian
government to arrest me I don't give a
who you I don't give a what you want to
do in life but but don't tell kids about
it don't teach that school don't don't
push your agenda don't try to brainwash
people don't try to go past parents
don't try to go past all this and
brainwash people you cck yeah that's all
true like that is all true almost
everyone now not everybody but most
people especially if you're of a certain
age like if you're under say
55 you basic nobody really cares about
anyone's sexuality anymore and People
Want To Live and Let Live it's just a
thing especially if you're in the Gen X
situation like that's the we had done it
it was all good it wasn't cool to be
racist it wasn't cool to hate gays or
anything else then they decided to push
all of this in the schools relentlessly
tell you that if you didn't want your
kid learning about sex when they were in
fourth grade that you're a bigot and
you're a racist if you you get it you
get all of the stuff and the reason I'm
showing you the Strickland thing again
is because it's interesting the
messaging there everything he just said
are all the policies that the santis
pushed forth in Florida and was told he
was a horrible person for and they are
the exact same things that are now the
rocket fuel for Donald Trump and I think
it is worth noting because if you only
view the world in by turning on the news
and what what happened politically today
you will never you will always be about
6 months to a year behind what is going
on in the real world cuz that's real
world stuff and then that Downstream
from culture down Downstream from
culture thing gets you the political
version of all this one more on the UFC
uh here is UFC president Dana White uh
defending Strickland's right to just say
what he thinks you obviously give a Long
Leash to your Fighters about you know
what they can say when they are up there
with a UFC microphone and you getting
into territory of homophobia transphobia
like is there I don't give anybody a
leash well I'm saying you a leash I'm
like free
speech control what people say going to
tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any other human
being what to say what to think and
there's no leashes on any of
them what is your
question I was asking that question I'll
move on though yeah probably a good idea
yeah you that's ridiculous to say I give
somebody a leash Free Speech Brother
people can say whatever they want and
they can believe whatever they want all
right so that is the position of Dana
White who is the president of the UFC
it's not his job to police all of his
guys now interestingly I think you could
make a a slightly counterargument on
that in that these guys represent his
organization and he is allow you know if
they were up there saying we want to
murder all these people like obviously
he would have some issue with that but
the the overriding driving force of what
he's saying of course of course it's not
only completely right but it's it's what
we've always wanted no it's not what
we've always wanted it's what it's the
way we always kind of did it before this
woke thing infected absolutely
everything what's really amazing about
this is that Strickland he's going after
budl budlight is now one of the biggest
sponsors of UFC they gave Dana White a
ton of money and suddenly Dana White is
now promoting Bud Light again so no
nobody's perfect in any of all this but
I will certainly give Dana White credit
right there for being like Oh one of my
guys is going after my major sponsor and
I'm going to defend his right to do it
isn't isn't that seriously something so
everyone every single one of you
watching this you know what Sean
Strickland is talking about again the
colorful language whether he parsed
every word perfectly or not the the
reaction that he is having because you
people have pushed all of this on
everybody else well now it's a whole
bunch of us that that don't even make
sense as a group politically all pushing
back you are giving us the biggest
political movement in the history of the
world right now because you people
cannot stop and you also know that uh
this is not just happening in the UFC
it's also happening across mainstream
media we're going to show you some clips
from MSNBC that are going to knock your
socks off or your wig in this case
because I don't think Joy Reed really
has blonde hair we'll get to that in
just a second let me talk to you guys
about truly office guys this might sound
unbelievable but the quickest way to
secure your personal data is to ditch
mainstream office software providers
like Microsoft and Google who misuse
your data without your permission and
switch to a safer alternative like truly
office software once you switch you'll
never look back because truly office
software gives you peace of mind and
control over your personal data truly
office software is secure private
alternative to mainstream office
software it doesn't track or sell your
data giving you complete control over
your personal information and getting
started is easy right now they're
offering a free trial of truly office
software just for our viewers and
listeners so you can try it before you
buy just go to truly office.com / Rumble
to start your journey towards data
privacy and security before you commit
to another office software that invades
your privacy consider truly office
software it's the secure private
alternative you've been looking for go
to truly office.com rumbl right now and
try it for free this offer is limited so
don't miss out okay so now I want to
connect this to more widely what's going
on in the culture War and what is also
happening uh politically because again
these things are deeply deeply connected
and if you just ignore the culture part
you are always going to to be uh in slow
motion mode right what do I always say
truth is a Time relase pill these days
right everything seems to be just we all
kind of find out about things slow but
if you're paying attention that you can
actually lock in with the truth and know
what's going on so Tiffany Justice uh
she is the co-founder of moms for
Liberty I Know Tiffany I've seen her at
many events I think I've done their
podcast uh at least once or twice over
the years she is a absolutely lovely
woman who I think was mostly uh
apolitical throughout her life and then
as they were pushing all of this gender
nonsense and trans stuff and all of this
stuff on her kids and then her friends
kids and everything else uh she started
a group called moms for Liberty they're
one of the groups that started looking
into some of the books that kids were
learning uh that kids were supposed to
read they started looking into the
curriculum that they were being taught
etc etc she is by no honest assessment
an extremist or a right-wing Maniac or
anything else but of course that's what
the media calls her anyway she went on
the televised mental institution known
as MSM NBC to talk to Joy Reed uh and
joy tried to explain to her why children
learning about pedophilia should be in
public schools the question I'm asking
is what is the expertise that you have
and other moms for Liberty Advocates
have to decide that a book an
award-winning book like all boys aren't
blue isn't appropriate for students to
read what is what a tragic story of a
young man who's anally raped by his
adult family member so you have incest
rape pedophilia Joy you said you'd let
me answer so I'm going to answer for you
um in what context is a strap on dildo
acceptable for public school just let I
mean that's my question to you tell me
what the context around the strap on
dildo or the rape of a minor Child by a
teacher second we're talking about
public school one moment right so now
you've asked me questions so I'm going
I'm going to answer it well who is the
main character what's the name of the
main character in all boys a aren't blue
you're asking me right now you just gave
me very specific information about this
book so you're presenting yourself as
somebody expert the who's the main
character in the book The main character
is the author who's the what's his name
George I believe is his first name
because you're giving me very specific
information that is remember the name of
an author Remember speciic here's my
question talking about you didn't answer
my question I'm going to I'm going to
answer your question great I would love
to hear that absolutely well I I'm
interviewing you and you're not
interviewing me so let's just make sure
it's a conversation okay great okay Joy
is just so absolutely unbearable that
tries to pin this down on you don't know
the name of the main character she knows
that it's George she knows that it's an
autobi you know that it's biographical
etc etc it's just it's such nonsense and
she knows what the story is about but
that's just like a little trick that if
you're a really um dishonest host you
can use on somebody like if I'm
interviewing somebody and they kind of
don't know what they're doing there's
always a way you can really just get
them on some BS and that's exactly what
Joy Reed did I think even for the dumb
brainlets that are watching MSNBC they
probably could see through that first I
want to just say say that someone has to
decide what's in curriculum so when Joy
is like well this is an award-winning
book and why should someone no kid is
taught the sum totality of all
information every year of their life
right every year you there are Educators
and and parents and board members that
get together to decide what is
appropriate for these children just if
you're watching this just think back to
when you were in third fourth grade
right think about your teacher I think
my third grade teacher Mrs kachin hour
absolutely loved her she read us uh the
Secret Garden and she did all the voices
I just absolutely adored this woman I
thought she was like 160 years old she
was probably like 65 or something but
that that's part of growing up but
imagine if she was instead of reading
The Secret Garden to us if she was
reading this book about anal rape and
dildos and incest and everything else um
that probably wouldn't have been right
it's not to say those things don't exist
because they do but they are appropriate
at some point and when that point should
be is subjective and that's why why
parents ultimately should be the
deciders of what their children are
learning and by the way we all know this
which is why the homeschooling movement
and the Pod movement uh and school
choice is exploding right now because
everyone's realizing boy you know for
Generations now we've been sending these
kids to learn about a whole bunch of
weird and now a bunch of kids have
anxiety they're all on drugs etc etc
anyway it continued with Joy Reed but uh
Tiffany did a fine job here I'm saying
to you is that as you are not an expert
in this book I don't have to AR for
publico I mean let's get is a full
context story as you said of the
author's experience why is it your right
or a mom's for Liberty activist's right
to say that a parent who wants their
child to have access to this book which
gives a personal experience of this
author that they that why doesn't a
liberal parent for instance or a parent
of an lgbtq kid why don't they have a
right for their child to just have
access to this book why why is it your
right to say they can't so again we're
talking about incest rape and pedophilia
parent each parent has to decide what is
appropriate for their child to read so I
want you to answer I'm going to ask you
one more time what is your right to tell
a parent who wants their child who might
feel seen by this story why don't they
have the right why don't they have the
right as a parent to say my child can
have access to this book if a child
feels seen by this story that means that
they have been uh the victim of a
predator that means that they have
either been raped by a family member
they they've experienced um and your
proof of that is what you just said that
a child feels seen by this
story you're now making assumptions but
if a child has been raped we should do a
lot better than put a book on Li you're
literally creating a story behind a
child that you don't know let me show
you a
form can't say all the things can't say
them nobody no's going to make any money
around here if I say them so let me try
to do it nicer first off when Joy keeps
saying uh are you an expert in this book
do you think that that in thus that
would give you the right to criticize
the book do you think the teachers who
are teaching this book or any other book
are experts in this book no they're
Elementary School teachers in public
schools they're not they're not
necessarily the best and the brightest
that's number one number two Joy if you
really want when she talks about the
parents of the lgbtq and and the and the
liberal parents if they really want
their child their fourth grader to learn
about anal rape and all of this other
stuff then give them that book at home
and then guess what Tiffany and moms for
Liberty might have they might question
the ethics or the morality of that
parent but at that point it's not their
right to do anything when we're talking
about a public school every parent gets
on the board right like the parents can
be as involved as they want most parents
obviously over the last two three
decades have not been involved enough so
people like Joy Reed were able to infect
all of these things but if but when Joy
Reed's like what are you saying
everything should be taught like it just
doesn't even make any sense uh James
Lindsay who is who is one of the
absolute best at really distilling down
what this woke movement really is he's
been on the show many times you know
James Lindsay uh he wrote this he he
retweeted the the clip that we just
showed you he wrote anyone who will lie
to you the way Joy Reed lies to Tiffany
Justice here will kill you the second
they have clearance and need to do so
what he's really connecting that to
although it it's kind it sort of sounds
over the top that that Joy re would kill
someone like that but what do Marxist
movements do how many people have died
in the name of Communism right because
the individual is the antithesis to the
Communist system so if you want some
autonomy over your life if you want some
autonomy over your children's life you
have to be eliminated so I don't think
James means that even though it sounds a
little over the top I don't think he
means it sarcastically that if these
people had the power to take out the
rest of us because we're right what are
we we're the bigots we're the racists
we're the homophobes we're the
transphobes you could be black but if
you don't believe in that you're
the bad guy you're gay but you don't
believe that you're the bad guy so it's
just so what Joy Reed is doing right
there is just like the Canadian reporter
that we talked about earlier in that
Strickland clip they're passionate about
these woke social issues but they will
gladly use the most authoritarian
Tendencies to shut people down so they
love their tolerant and woke and verse
but they'll also shut down your bank
they'll also make sure that you can't
protest they'll also force you to be
injected with things or make sure you
don't have a job because it is all faux
tolerance and diversity and now more and
more people are stepping up against it
anyway one more from uh MSNBC because
ali veli uh joined Joy Reed uh to
dissect what just happened there and
well here's this so this idea that these
books are just pushed back because
people don't want this idea of learning
other people's story stories to be out
there it's just it's disingenuous to
call it all about sex kids know all
about sex kids have always known all
about sex in fact if there's anything to
do it to do a better job ensuring that
kids get proper sex education because
the the correlation is is direct if kids
get proper sex education they have safer
sex lives they they they don't get
pregnant as early things like that
happens it's not your right to tell
anyone when their children should learn
about sex right it's up to parents you
know on a personal note here you got
most of you watching this know this I'm
gay we have kids right this has nothing
to do with being gay and this has
nothing to do with uh it has everything
to do with parenting it has nothing to
do with sexuality in a weird sense right
like I wouldn't want my kids going to a
school and learning about sex or
sexuality or anything else before
they've learned about it from me right
like that that is just such an obvious
truth but these people want to corrupt
the minds of young people that's not
because because being gay is bad that's
not the truth they want to corrupt the
minds of young people so that they can
so that they can basically get them to
believe anything else they want them to
believe what right does Ali veli have to
decide when Tiffany Justice's child
should learn about sex or gender or
sexuality or anything else if Joy Reed
again really wants her child to learn
the story of anal rape then read that to
your own child it's about parental
rights but again they want to remove all
of the individuals from the system and
you will bow to us now I want to shift
this to something we talked a bit about
last week because the world economic
Forum had their yearly Conference of
lunacy and uh wait are we doing that
right now yeah oh we're gonna do an ad
and then we'll talk about the world
economic Conference of lunacy let's talk
about ad tax Network USA guys are you
struggling with your back taxes or
unified Returns the IRS is escalating
collections adding 20 20,000 new agents
and sending over 5 million collection
letters to kickoff 2024 in these
challenging times your best defense is
tax Network USA don't let the IRS take
advantage of you with over 14 years of
experience tax Network USA has saved
their clients over a billion in back
taxes no matter the size of your tax
issue their expertise is your advantage
they specialize in negotiating with the
IRS aiming to significantly reduce your
debt tax Network USA doesn't just
negotiate they also protect your assets
from IRS seizures and manage your yearly
returns for ongoing compliance
importantly they are licensed to help
with all state tax issues regardless of
where you live in the US the clock's
ticking don't wait as the IRS steps
steps up its game seize control of your
financial future now contact tax Network
USA for immediate relief and expert
guidance call 1800 245 6000 or visit TN
usa.com dve don't let tax issues
overpower you turn to tax Network USA
and find your path to Financial peace of
mind okay so let's connect all of this
whether we're talking about UFC fighters
pushing back on woke nonsense and just
saying enough is enough and a whole
thousands of people canting F Trudeau
who has pushed so much of this on on uh
decent Canadian citizens or whether
we're talking about a decent woman like
Tiffany Justice with moms for Liberty
who just wants her children to be taught
age appropriate things which we all knew
were right 20 years ago pushing back
against a woke leftist lunatic like Joy
Reed what that has all done has that
that issue the people that are just like
enough is enough that thing is the thing
that has brought Trump back that is just
true you might have been a disantis guy
you might have been this or that or the
other thing but what it is doing it is
taking all of these people I don't think
if you took someone like Tiffany Justice
mild-mannered mom who just wanted to
know what her kids were learning and you
connected her with Joe Rogan and
Strickland and Dana White like and then
you looked at boy these people are all
going to end up voting for the same
person why would that be it's a little
bit bizarre right but it's not that
bizarre because when people get pushed
into a corner eventually they do push
back it is built into the human system
so now I want to connect this to what we
were talking about last week which is
the world economic Forum uh JP Morgan
CEO Jamie Diamond was there and Diamond
I thought quite well explained why Trump
is back and why people uh support the
guy I wish the Democrats with think a
little more carefully when they talk
about Maga when people say Maga they're
actually looking at people voting for
Trump and they think they're voting and
they're basically scaping them that you
are like him uh and but I don't think
they're voting for Trump because his
family values if you look just take a
step back be honest he was kind of right
about NATO kind of right about
immigration he grew the economy quite
Wella tax reform worked he was right
about some of China I don't I don't like
what he did no I said China virus he may
have been right he I don't like how he
said things about Mexico I don't like
but he wasn't wrong about some these
critical issues and that's why they're
voting for him and and I think people
should be a little more respectful of
our fellow citizens and when you guys
have people up here you should always
ask the why not like it's a binary thing
you're supporting Trump you're not
supporting Trump why are you supp it's
hard to hate 75 million of your fellow
Americans and it's I agree done and you
know the Democrats have done a pretty
good job with the deplorables hugging on
their Bibles and their beer and their
guns I mean really could we just stop
that stuff and actually grow up and
treat other people with respect and
listen to him a little bit and and I do
think the economy will affect I think
this this negative talk about Maga is
going to hurt Biden's election campaign
yeah that's just right that's just right
because what's Jamie Diamond doing there
he's defending just the average American
just a mom who wants to know what her
kid is learning right just a person who
works at a company and doesn't want to
be discriminated against because they
happen to be straight and white but all
of these people have pushed so far that
they have actually uh summoned Donald
Trump from the Gates of Hell once again
so this is the last time I promise you
this is the last time I'm going to do it
on on this show for the next year I
thought that there was a different way
we could go let's say in the Republican
party to fix this I thought there was a
younger version that made more sense but
I fully got what was going on here it
was also exactly why I voted for Donald
Trump in the first place I by no
estimation am the typical Trump
supporter or republican or anything else
but he absolutely will have my support
gladly he will gladly have my support in
the face of what we are going against
right now and more and more people are
understanding that um I want to show you
a clip this is from a couple years back
actually you'll note that because
Charlie Rose is no longer on television
he had his own little sex scandal but
this on the Charlie Rose show a
legendary author and original feminist
Camille Pia talking about what the
average American wants out of our
education system now this is literally
from like 20 years ago or so but listen
to what she talks about versus what Joy
Reed and the rest of these woke lunatics
are constantly pushing on us enlightened
and enlightened multiculturalism okay I
I I'm totally opposed to any politicized
agenda in in in the classroom okay I do
not want this crappy melodrama being
taught to our students that Western
Civilization is filled with evil
Patriarchs and out there are the
wonderful people of color okay well but
I don't think anyone that I know of that
believ that that well just what you just
said the new historicist listen you
don't know stepen greenl the new
historicist okay who are I mean my God
every word out of their mouth is about
the evil of Western culture you know how
Western culture is evil and all you
don't know how bad Asian or African
culture is is unflawed these people
these people in the who have have
control of the universities humanties
departments now do not believe in great
art okay you know it's funny we didn't
speed that up I know she's talking like
this we didn't speed that up but talk
about somebody being right so long ago
that that might even be 30 years ago we
we'll try to get the can we try to get
the exact date on that but the point is
people have known that the institutions
were infected she was way ahead of the
curve on it if you think I've been a
little ahead of the curve on what was
going on with the woke or Jordan
Peterson has her Ben Shapiro it's like
there's somebody that was in it right
and she was calling it out and Charlie
Rose trying to be sort of the good Lial
listen to what you just said that sounds
mean or something like that but all
she's saying in essence is the thing
that again we all knew which is the
reverse of what the woke want which is
get politics get your social agenda out
of schools when I was growing up and I
went to all public schools and I also
went to a public college but when I went
to school you learned math you learned
science you didn't learn that boys were
girls and the rest of the nonsense and
you didn't know if your teacher was gay
or straight or anything else and they
didn't have a flag on their desk that
said this or that they taught you things
and then you went home you didn't even
realize that they were real people I
remember once I saw my gym teacher and
the art teacher Mr Mr Myers and miss
Anderson I saw them at Macy's on the
escalator this has got to be around 1986
I was probably about 10 years old and I
thought it was the craziest thing ever
how could the gym teacher be with the
art teacher at a
store I guess they were just shopping I
don't know uh that was in 1992 32 years
ago that she said that man is my coffee
working today or what uh anyway uh let's
connect this to everything else because
once they break your child's brain with
all of those things then eventually
generations of those people get out into
society and then generation of people
start taking over our institutions and
then nothing works you know what's one
of those things that's not working right
now it's our border our border is not
working a border is a thing it's
supposed to be a literal physical thing
like a wall let's say but at the very
least it's it's something that's written
on a map that delineates between
countries let's say between the Mexico
and the United States and the Canada and
the United States well right now we know
that because of the Democrat
policies uh that have been instilled
well certainly in these last couple
years under the Biden Administration uh
we we are under an invasion we are under
an absolute Invasion I want I was in New
York City over the weekend I was doing
that that Gutfeld thing that we showed
you at the top of the show uh but I want
to show you this on what's going on this
is not for me but this was happening
this weekend in New York City migrants
have just taken over the
[Music]
city
you
[Music]
all right that video goes on and on and
on I don't think we have to belabor the
point but but what I want to connect
this to is what Jamie Diamond said that
when you demonize all of these people uh
you're going to start creating a problem
so it does not make you a bigot to not
want your third grader to learn about
anal rape in school by some activist and
it doesn't make you a racist to wonder
why are all these people wandering
through New York City and who what do
they think and what are their intentions
and why are they here right and having
been in New York City this past week and
a city that I loved and adored that I
that I lived in for about 15 years as an
adult when all all my good old days
stories are from New York when I had
when I didn't have a freaking two dimes
to rub together and I stood out on
street corners with a dream that that I
that miraculously came true and you're
watching it right now um and I and I
lived through 9/11 in New York City and
all of those things it was once the
greatest place in the world New York
City was the place that everyone
everywhere wanted to come to the the
streets were lined with gold right like
that was the idea here's New York City
in 1945 you know I love these throwback
videos
[Music]
I just love those videos we could have
sh you a lot more of that you can you
can find those videos online they're
they're just wonderful to see because
the streets are clean the cars are nice
the people are well-dressed it doesn't
mean everything was perfect but it's a
hell of a lot better than what's going
on there right now where New York City
every single Corner smells like a
combination of weed and urine every
single corner there are no business
people left it it is it is just an
abject nightmare so the problem is and
the point of all of this is that normal
Americans just want a normal America
back and most of us are actually normal
within whatever the parameters of
something kind of roughly normal are
that's how most of us are but the
activist lunatics over here have just
driven us all together and that doesn't
mean there aren't activist lunatics on
the right but that is not the major
problem at the moment so what else
happens what else happens when you teach
everyone all the wrong things when you
have no borders you have no law you're
allowed to steal stuff Urban Decay all
of that then you start actually
importing people who want to kill you
literally kill you this is the most
chilling video you are going to see all
month I guarantee you this video which
was taken over the weekend it's a it's a
middle eastern illegal immigrant and
wait till you hear what he says it's
just absolutely incredible this should
be the lead story on every news program
tonight because there should be a
national Manhunt for this guy and you
are not going to see this on mainstream
media anywhere take a look by the way if
you are smart enough you would know who
I am but you are really not smart enough
to know who I am but soon you're going
to know who I am very easy wow very easy
the the entitlement the entitlement no
believe me I'm much bitter than that the
entitlement guys wow okay so there you
have an illegal immigrant the accent
would lead you to believe from the
Middle East there's some issues in the
Middle East at the moment and there he
is saying if you were smart enough you
would know who I am you will all know
who I am do you guys remember 911 do you
remember
107 uh like if that guy does something
that is on Joe Biden and that is on
mayorcas and it is on the Democrats but
that video like here's a guy saying you
will all know who I am why are you
inventing a great widget that we're all
going to buy probably not right like
what but guys it's not just our borders
it's our airports we are letting these
people in and then we're letting them
fly all over the place you may have seen
this uh this is uh this is is a tweet
from me from a picture that I took as I
was en route on Thursday I was en route
from Miami going to uh New York to do
Gutfeld and I saw this I was on the
pre-tsa line and I saw the image that
you see there I wrote this this is the
state of absolute Insanity happening at
our airports I'm in the pre-tsa line
where migrants don't have to have an ID
to get through security and it's their
choice whether they want their picture
taken there is a plan to destroy America
this was retweeted a gajillion times
senators were retweeting it it was
covered on most Fox shows can we throw
back to it for just a sec because I just
want to show so so if you are a
non-citizen now I'm in the pre-tsa line
so the prsa line you've already
pre-screened to be in that line so why
this sign was there I don't know but if
you're an illegal notify the TSA officer
that you're a migrant the TSA offer will
take a photo but that's optional three
if requested maybe it won't be provide
your alien documentation number for Oro
biographic information I've never even
heard of that word and then follow the
officer instructions and then repeatedly
it says that it's your choice whether
you want your picture taken so we have
laws and regulations for us the
nonsensical Ridiculousness that goes on
at TSA where they rub you down and they
they touch you while they're smiling at
you in a weird way but if you're a
migrant well you you want your picture
taken or not come on you want it you
want a new head shot what do you need
what do you need it is
absolutely insane it's insane but it
should be expected because we've all
seen all of this coming now I want to
show you a video uh this guy is a you
know we don't really have Democrat Party
here in Florida anymore we have
completely demolished the Democrat Party
as you know Des santis won by 20 points
there is no functioning Democrat Party
here but we do still have a couple
Democrat uh uh Congress people here in
Florida this is a guy by the name of Max
Frost he's up in Orlando which is one of
the last bluish areas in all of Florida
this is the very same guy you may
remember this when I did my show in
Orlando with Governor DeSantis last year
during my book tour uh this is a guy who
bum rushed the state age and then took
video of it and put it in his campaign
ad to become congressman okay so this
guy he has no problem infringing on
other people's Free Speech uh but here
he is in Congress uh lecturing us on
Republicans being mean about immigration
and what we should do about it to my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle let's be honest with immigrants
who deserve better than what you're
offering them don't welcome immigrants
if you plan to reject them if you keep
pushing your bigoted hr2 bill then also
pass this bill I've taken the liberty of
drafting it for you it removes the
Statue of Liberty our largest symbol
that tells people to come here this is
who you are removing the fabric of
America so I want to know which
Republican who supports and voted for
hr2 will introduce this bill oh shut the
up these people that's the attitude
that's the attitude that you mean I try
not to say the f- word my mom watches
the show and she's always telling me
Dave control the f-words she calls me
David David control the F bombs um but
enough enough of these people that's the
attitude that Strickland has that's the
attitude that camil palia had 30 years
ago that's the attitude that Tiffany
Justice was having towards Joy Reed
enough it's the attitude that Donald
Trump has to the whole damn system and
that is exactly why Donald Trump is back
he's back baby right he is and we all
know why now yes yes Republicans are so
mean that we should take down the
Statute of Liberty you are supposed to
have legal immigration we have no Duty
to give anyone anything nothing none
Zippo zch so let's bring this thing full
circle what is the motive what do you
think the actual motive for this policy
is that for this policy that's killing
America what is actually happening here
well it's woke multiculturalism and it
is here to destroy everything that by
the way is James Lindsay's point when he
says these people will kill you they are
here to destroy America don't believe me
check this out this is the director of
the American Military project his name
is will theu he is a what appears to be
a straight white guy but here he is uh
telling Congress that diversity equity
and inclusion are deeply deeply
important diversity is an ideology that
exists in our social m is is something
that the military must Embrace as a
point of fact as a principle as opposed
to just a byproduct of selecting the
best people for the
job it's as if the Armed Forces marched
to the beat of a corporate or university
drum in reality though the existence of
a professional permanent standing
military demands that the institution
exist apart from ideologies and politics
prevalent in modern day America
regardless of their political
affiliation wait did I slightly is he
pushing for diversity equ he is pushing
for it right it got a little screwy
there at the end uh it sort of sounded
like no maybe he was backtracking but no
these are the people that have now we
know this this is in our military right
like how many trans people are running
our our rocket ships like it's
absolutely everywhere and by the way
guys it's Global now uh it is it is
global and it is being pushed Again by
that world economic Forum the elites who
don't really like the fact that you get
to decide what you eat what you're
eating steak we're the only ones that's
supposed to eat steak what you're flying
on a on a plane we're the ones that are
supposed to be on private planes so now
let's go back to the world economic
Forum last week in Davos Switzerland
here is Alex Soros he is the son of ego
or megalomaniac uh psychotic lunatic
George Soros who has pushed so much of
this anti-western stuff on our free
independent nations uh he is also
running most of uh George soros's
operations at this point because George
is is up there in years uh here he is
given a speech about the amount of
people who will vote in this upcoming
year across the globe he appears to be
drugged and Confused uh but this is this
is now the guy that is sort of replacing
his dad take a listen um but um you know
I um I don't think that that's the I
don't think that that's the fundamental
I don't think technology is the
fundamental issue uh in in democracy
democracy is messy I mean you know
democracy is about contestation of ideas
it's about uh plurality um it's about
people having different truths actually
now if we play too much on this
thisinformation card we're taking the
responsibility away from ourselves to
actually create a narrative that
inspires people to vote and to believe
uh you know in um uh in uh in democracy
and Democratic um institutions done the
institutional part I think that we can
talk about uh institutions as these
abstract things but institutions are
also about people and um you know um you
know we just heard this this this point
about untrustworthy people and we talked
about things in the United States like
you know like um checks and balances
which aren't written anywhere but are
customs and one man Donald Trump
literally came in and just took that you
know took that took that all away um you
know so um you know so um you know but
when I see this um you know I think that
we really have to be careful here in you
know in this Nostalgia uh for a time uh
you know for a Time past because a lot
of the reactions we're seeing in society
are actually reactions to POS positive
uh to positive things like you know like
equality uh for women um you know uh and
um uh you know and greater diversity uh
which come with that Clash
um program breaking
down the drugs
here um in essence what he is saying is
that Donald Trump somehow is the enemy
of what they are really trying to do
they want you to believe in democracy as
long as it's their version of democracy
so what he's very concerned about right
now is that
4.2 billion people worldwide are going
to vote in elections this year and
especially the American election is of
course the most important one and he's
basically saying we better get these
people to vote the way we want them to
vote otherwise we'll end up with that
Donald Trump guy again and you know what
happens if you end up with that Donald
Trump guy that's the signal to the rest
of the world that they have some
autonomy over their borders that they
have some autonomy over their values and
culture and everything else and that
would be the worst thing possible if you
were a globalist if you were someone who
just thought oh there's one way to look
at the world and if we could just uh
basically install people in different
countries who didn't really believe in
the founding documents of their own
countries but believed in our globalist
vision uh then uh things would be good
so someone like Justin Trudeau remember
F Trustin Trudeau that's where we
started he's a perfect world economic
Forum puppet he doesn't stand up for
anything that's remotely close to a
Canadian value he stands up for for
globalist values but the problem is the
wef gets their hooks into all of these
political leaders uh this is a some a
picture of the Polish foreign minister
radic Sikorski uh and he held a private
meeting with
that with Alex Soros at the world
economic forum and uh the N wokeness
account they wrote rip Poland it was fun
while it lasted why do these people why
do these people get involved in all of
our governments what right does George
Soros or Alex Soros have to influence
the leaders of these countries to take
away the rights of their people right
and and by the way these are also many
of the bad people come from America
itself here's Bill Gates and guess what
more vaccines more consumption more
control he's planning it we make sure
that for all these
vaccines uh that there's enough capacity
uh that there's competition so the
prices keep going going down and we will
have new vaccines we'll have a a TB
vaccine malaria vaccine HIV vaccine and
even the things like covid vaccines we
need to make them have longer duration
more coverage uh and we're going to
change instead of using the needle to
use a little patch uh so the pandemic
really highlighted that we've been
underinvested in those Innovations and
you know our partners in India are are
part of how we're going to get these
breakthrough products done God the way
he smiles when he's looking and talking
about all these things we don't want
your vaccines you're you're the ones
that are coming up with all the diseases
in the first place uh you during
lockdowns were able to live at any of
your multitude dozen or so houses your
your people still worked for you you
weren't you you people are disgusting
and gross we want nothing to do with you
we don't like you okay that's what I
want to say I also want to say that you
know Bill Gates of course became famous
for and and became a billionaire because
he created Microsoft Windows you know
you know remember back in the day PCs
were just like C prompt this that and
then he gave us sort of the visual
interpretation that was Windows and we
had paint and all that other stuff but
Windows of course and Microsoft the
thing that took out windows basically in
most Microsoft programs which then led
to the rise of Apple was they were
infected by viruses do you remember that
so he creates this operating system and
then you'd go on your computer to just
go to a website and then a zillion other
pop-ups we got we got to play one of
those next time we show a Bill Gates
clip a zillion other pop-ups and you'd
have to get virus softare paper that
virus and then oh there' be a new virus
and you get right patch he's just he's
just taken what he created that virus
Laden that they created
digitally and now they've put it into
the real world with all of this nonsense
uh but what's what's a good way of
pushing back against these people how
about it's living a healthy life how
about it's not believing everything they
say uh there is a guy who's doing that
this is a throwback clip but then we're
going to get you to one from this past
weekend I remember the best tennis
player of all time Novak jokovic uh when
he shut down a reporter over his
decision not to get the CO jab it's
worth noting in the in the face of that
Bill Gates nonsense let's throw back to
that one I understand the consequences
of my decision and one of the
consequences of my decision was not
going to Australia and I was prepared
not to go and I understand that not
being vaccinated today I you know I'm
unable to travel to most of the
tournaments at the moment and that's the
price you're willing to pay that that is
the price that I'm willing to pick
ultimately are you prepared to
forego the chance to be the greatest
player that ever picked up a racket
statistically because you feel so
strongly about this
jab
yes I do but as things stand if this
means that you miss the French Open is
that a price you'd be willing to pay yes
that is the price that I'm willing to
pay and if it means that you miss Will
Wimbledon this year again that's a price
you're willing to pay
yes why Novak why what because the
principles of uh decision making on my
body uh are more important than any
title or anything else I'm I'm I'm
trying to be in tune with my body isn't
that so great when you have the truth
why why why won't you get that injection
why won't you show up to it's my body
I'm going to do what I think is right
now the reason I'm showing you that is
because this past weekend Novak jokovic
was at the Aussie open and listen to
this there's a man you're going to hear
it screaming get vaccinated uh while
he's about to serve uh you might enjoy
this
one full match points
[Applause]
please
6 how absolutely great is that like how
great is that get vaccinated the crowd's
not with that guy anymore the crowd
loves novic jokovic now and then just
freaking blows it by just absolute
straight up just blows by the opponent
that's what it's all about standing up
for what you believe and doing what you
think is right living in a way that is
congruent with what your brain knows and
what we've known for years and years and
years as opposed to being the to
these people who would gladly jail you
you tell the truth like camil paleo was
talking about 30 years ago here's a
little little clip from that again
enlightened and enlightened
Multicultural I I I'm totally opposed to
any politicized agenda in in the
classroom okay I do do not want this
crappy melodrama being taught to our
students that Western Civilization is
filled with evil Patriarchs and out
there are the wonderful people of color
okay well but I don't think anyone that
I know so there's Camille paa doing it
30 years ago telling the truth a truth
that we that now we're all seeing so
we're getting the push back on and then
other people are waking up guys like
Sean Strickland who really just wanted
to beat the crap out of other people who
a living but instead he has to beat the
crap out of woke Canadian reporters but
I did want to ask also things you said
about the trans community you said uh
this past October when they announced
the budlight sponsorship that you'd go
so hard on budlight in your next fight
they'll have to accept me or denounce me
when uh when they know what and will
know what they stand for are you this
guy's like this Canadian is not that
Canadian are you still going to use your
fight time to kind of speak on that
here's the thing about Bud
Light here's the thing about Bud
Light 10 years ago to be trans was a
what a mental illness and now all of a
sudden people like you have weasel your
way in the world
you are you are an
infection you are the definition of
weakness everything that is wrong with
the world is because of you and the best
thing is is the world's not buying it
the world's not buying your bull you're
pedling the world is not saying you know
what you're right chicks have dicks the
world's not saying that
world that's what the world's not saying
what is the point of all of this guys
well uh as I said at the top of the show
it is always worth fighting the good
fight it does not mean you will win
every battle you will not win every
political battle you will not win every
battle in your home or in your community
but it is always worth fighting for
truth it is always worth being brave
marching forward and never quitting when
you know you are doing the right
thing and it doesn't mean you're going
to be president at the end either here's
Ronda santis checking out of the
election greetings from from Florida the
warmth of being home is a reminder why
I've chosen public service from joining
the United States Navy and serving in
Iraq to representing the people in the
US Congress and now serving as governor
of Florida and it reminds me why I
decided to run for president to fight
for those who have been forgotten in
this country this is America's time for
choosing we can choose to allow a border
Invasion or we can choose to stop it we
can choose Reckless borrowing and
spending or we can choose to limit
government and lower inflation we can
choose political indoctrination or we
can choose classical education these
choices are symptoms of the underlying
struggle to ensure that constitutional
government can endure and that Western
Civilization can survive and we launched
this campaign to bring accountability to
government regain sovereignty at our
border and restore sanity to our society
we cannot succeed as a country if we
allow our nation to be invaded our
currency to be debased our cities to
crumble and our kids to be indoctrinated
the DC Elites who facilitated this mess
do not care about you and they do not
work for you they work for themselves
they seek to accumulate power at your
expense to pursue an agenda that is
harmful to the American people citizens
do not serve politicians it is the duty
of politicians to serve you talk is
cheap actions speak louder than words
reversing the decline of this nation
requires leadership that delivers big
results for the people we are elected to
serve it's clear to me that a majority
of Republican primary voters want to
give Donald Trump another chance they
watch his presidency get stymied by
Relentless resistance and they see
Democrats using lawfare this day to
attack him well I've had disagreements
with Donald Trump such as on the Corona
virus pandemic and his elevation of
Anthony fouchy Trump is superior to the
current incumbent Joe Biden that is
clear I signed a pledge to support the
Republican nominee and I will honor that
pledge he has my endorsement because we
can't go back to the old Republican
guard of yester year a repackaged formed
of warmed over corporatism that Nikki
Haley represents the days of putting
Americans last of cow to to large
corporations of caving to woke ideology
are over Winston Churchill once remarked
that Success is Not final failure is not
fatal it is the courage to continue that
counts while this campaign has ended the
mission continues down here in Florida
we will continue to show the country how
to lead thank you and God bless that's
the point guys you will not always win I
will not always win we may we will not
always win right but you have a chance
to be a Sean Strickland and push back
you have a chance to be a Tiffany
Justice and push back you have a chance
to be way ahead of the curve and be
Camille Pia and push back you have a
chance to be the guy who's fought the
woke better than anybody in the last
five years like Ronda santis and push
back you have a chance to be a guy like
Javier Malay in Argentina and go to the
world economic forum and tell them that
they can go f themselves or you have a
chance to be like Donald Trump and be
the guy that's going to push back in a
way that they actually cannot
fathom or they can chop your genitals
off the choice is yours happy Monday bye
I am black I am gay I am disabled
I am a woman seeking to control her
health and her
[Music]
choices